- [Interviewer] All right, so, Gwen.
Gwen, where are you from
originally, where'd you grow up?
- [Gwen] I grew up in Kansas.
- [Interviewer] What city?
- [Gwen] A little town called Coffeyville.
- [Interviewer] Okay, tell
me about your childhood,
you grew up with both parents?
- I grew up with both parents,
but they were never together.
So it was like one weekend with my mom
and one weekend with my
dad, go back and forth.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
What age were you when they got divorced?
- I was a little, little kid.
I was not even a year
old yet, I don't think,
when they got divorced.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
how was your childhood?
- I had a good childhood.
- [Interviewer] It was fine?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You got along
with both your mom and dad?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] What age were
you when you left Kansas?
- Well, things were kind of weird,
I lived in New York for
a lot of my childhood.
So from the time I was
born, really, to like six,
I was living in New York.
And then from six to 19 is
when I was living in Kansas.
For about a year I lived in Oklahoma,
then went back to Kansas.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And how long you been
in the adult industry?
- About a week.
- [Interviewer] A week,
so you're brand new?
- Brand new, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what
attracted you to it?
- It's something I've always wanted to do.
I'm a very open person about my sexuality
and it looked really fun, honestly,
just to be able to kind of be myself
and do things that I enjoy,
and be in an environment where it's okay
to like those things.
Where I grew up,
it's like everyone's very
conservative and stuff,
so people didn't really like me too much.
They thought I was a bad person
because I was adventurous
or I wore certain clothes
that they didn't like to see people in.
So being in the industry allows me
to explore aspects of myself
without having a negative
stigma as much, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What is
it about your personality
that kind of like led you to that?
I mean, do you think it's something,
you're just naturally more
free with your sexuality?
- [Gwen] Um, yeah, I think-
- [Interviewer] Were you always that way?
You're young yet, how old are you?
- [Gwen] 21.
- [Interviewer] 21.
- [Gwen] Yeah, I've always
been kind of open about it
and I've always liked trying new things.
I'm someone who's not
scared to try anything new
and I'll do anything to
see if I like it or not.
So it's same way with like
trying new things sexually.
I've never shied away from anything,
I've gotta try it to see if I enjoy it.
And it's just always been that way,
ever since I was like 12, 13,
is when I started having sex
and like exploring that aspect of my life.
So I just, from a young age,
I kind of gained experience
doing certain things.
So I've always had that knowledge.
- [Interviewer] Do your
parents know you're doing it?
- [Gwen] No.
- [Interviewer] They don't know?
- [Gwen] They don't know, no.
- [Interviewer] So does that,
do any of your friends know or?
- [Gwen] My roommate knows
- Your roommate?
- that I'm doing it, yeah.
And he's super supportive
of it, he thinks it's cool.
And he's glad that I'm like
doing something that I enjoy
and finding the time to
explore something for myself.
- [Interviewer] Did you
just move to California?
- I'm staying with someone, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
you're not even totally-
- Yeah, I'm not totally
moved anywhere yet, but yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Have you done your first scene yet?
- Yeah, I've done two.
- [Interviewer] And how is,
what was your experience
after doing the first scene?
- It was really nice.
Everyone's really welcoming
and they make sure to ask you
a whole bunch of questions
about what you're comfortable with,
what you aren't comfortable with.
And a lot of times they
tell you a word to say
or an action to do if
you wanna take a break.
And so it's just a really safe environment
and everyone's super nice
all the time, and it's great.
- [Interviewer] It's great?
'Cause it has a reputation
as being other than that, so.
- Yeah, and it's very welcoming,
everyone has guided me.
Like, if I have any
questions, they're answered,
and everyone I've worked
with has given me tips
and told me do's and don'ts
and just how to be more
comfortable and everything.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well, good luck with everything.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Thank you
so much for talking to me
and hope everything works out for you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] All right, thank you.